اعلنت الولايات المتحده حضرا معدات
وتكنولوجيا الاتصالات التي تقدمها خمس
شركات صينيه واعاده النظر في التراخيص
التي سبق ان منحتها لشراء مثل تلك الخدمات
من شركات صينيه وتتزامن هذه الخطوه التي
تقول واشنطن انها تهدف لحمايه الامن
القومي الامريكي مع اعلان البلدين عزمهم
توجهها نحو اعاده الهدوء الى العلاقات
الثنائيه بينهما
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله اتخاذ
الولايات المتحده هذه الخطوه بالتزامن مع
تاكيد واشنطن وبيجين عزمهم التوافق على
مساحات التفاهم في ملفات التجاره والامن
ثم مخيره الصين للتعامل مع القرار
الامريكي بتقييد التكنولوجيا الاتصالات
القادمه منها في ضوء وصفها مثل هذه
القرارات سابقا بالمقوضه للعلاقه بين
البلدين ثم نبحث في على اي نحو يمكن ان
ينعكس هذا القرار على العلاقات التجاريه
بين واشنطن وبيجين في هذا التوقيت وعلى
الدول التي تستخدم تكنولوجيا الاتصالات
صيدليه
[موسيقى]
بعد 10 ايام فقط من تاكيد الرئيس الامريكي
جو بيدين عقب لقائه نظره الصيني
والحيلوله دون تحول المنافس بينهما الى
صراع اعلى لا تسلطات الامريكيه حظر
المعدات وخدمات الاتصالات التي تقدمها خمس
شركات صينيه بينها شركه هواوي
وشركات اخرى تنتجوا اجهزه مراقبه
وتكنولوجيا رقميه القرار الذي اتخذته لجنه
الاتصالات الفيدراليه الامريكيه يشمل ايضا
الابقاء على قرارات الحضر المماثله على
منتجات الشركات التكنولوجيا اتصالات صينيه
بل واعاده النظر في التاريخ التي سبق ان
منحتها لاستيراد التكنولوجيا المعلومات من
الصين وفي تبريرها لهذا القرار قالت
اللجنه انه جزء مهم من الاجراءات التي
تهدف لحمايه الشعب الامريكي مما سمته
تهديدات للامن القومي تستخدم فيها معدات
اتصالاته
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا منه
واشنطن الدكتور ماثيو اوكرانيك المستشار
السابق بوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ومن بيجين
فيكتوريا رئيس الجمعيه الصينيه للدراسات
الدوليه
اساله عن توقيت اتخاذ هذا القرار من قبل
واشنطن رغم ان الحديث عن المخاوف الامنيه
لدى واشنطن من هذه الشركات الصينيه ليس
جديده ما تفسير التوقيت الان
المساله قد تاخرت كان هذا قرار على
الولايات المتحده اتخذوا منذ سنوات في
الصين فعلا تستخدم هذه التقنيات لاهداف
التجسس وبالتالي كل البيانات
الامريكيه
كذلك
الصين سياسه تجمع بين التكنولوجيا
والمعدات المدنيه
والاهداف العسكريه
وبالتالي هذا يعتبر
الولايات المتحده الصينيه اول خاصه
ما دمت متاكد من هذه الاتهامات فهذا يصبح
معه السؤال ضروي اذا لماذا الان اتخذت
واشنطن هذا القرار ما دامت متاكده كما
تقول بان الصين تستعمل هذه البيانات
لاغراض استخباراتيه
الامريكيه على مريخ 25 عاما بعد نهايه
الحرب البارده امل الولايات المتحده
التفاعل مع الصين
يؤدي ذلك الى تعاونا اكبر ولكن الان نرى
تحت او بعوده الرئيس الصيني هذا لم ينجح
هذا الاستراتيجاء تفاعل يا فاشله شيء
اختار للصين مثلا اكثر عدائيه وبالتالي
غيرت واشنطن من استراتيجياتها حتى تصير
اكثر تنافسيه ضد
الصين في المجال الديبلوماسي والعسكري
والتجاري والان في مجال الاتصال
لماذا تتخذ واشنطن هذا القرار الان بعيده
ايام فقط من لقاء رئيسين الصيني الامريكي
القمه بين الرئيسين الامريكي
والصيني في بالك انا ناجح جدا فقط هدا
الوضع بين الدولتين وخفف من التوترات كذلك
بين الصين والغرب بسرعه ولكن هذا القرار
الامريكي الحكومي الجديد فعلا
اي مقاربه منصفه وعادل بالنسبه الى موضوع
تكنولوجيا النظر الى ما قاله ضيفكم
الامريكي حول استخدام هذه المعدات التجسس
اذا سمعنا الى ادويه
الحكومه التي تمارس هذه الممارسات وليست
الحكومه الامريكيه هذا ضربه من الخيال هذا
اولا ثانيا الولايات المتحده قد تعتبر
اكبر قوه في العالم ولكن من خلال المقاربه
غير المنصفه والعادله من اجل
منعي التجاره بطريقه المنصف هذا ليس مؤشرا
قوا بل هو مؤشر شعور بالضعف وهكذا يرى
العالم بام العين لماذا تشارك الولايات
المتحده بين الممارسات غير المنصفه غير
العادله تمنع تجهيزات والمعدات الصينيه
التي هي رخيصه الثمن ويمكن الوثوق بها
والتي تم اختبارها وتجربه من قبل دول
مختلفه في العالم
هل حتى مع هذه الخطوه الامريكيه مزيده
تعتبر بان اللقاء بين الرئيسين كان ناجحه
هكذا
حكوميه الامريكيه مقلقه لانه لا يغير في
العلاقات العامه بين دولتين الصين في
تنانين وفي تقدم مستمر
فان حجم الاقتصاد الصيني سوف يتخطى حجم
الاقتصاد الامريكي ولكن بعد ان يحصل ذلك
الولايات المتحده سوف تبقى واا تشعر
بالراحه لانه ليس هناك تهديد تطرحه الصين
الصين تريد تفاعل الولايات المتحده تريد
ان تتفق معها تريد اعطيني كافه العالم على
انها على سواسيه بالتالي ليس هناك سبب لكي
تقلق الدول وان تفقد صوابها وان ترى
اشباحا وتتحدث عن حروب لا وجود لها الصين
موجوده كانت موجوده منذ خمسه الاف عام
ومهما فعلته الحكومه الامريكيه الان فهذا
لن ينكر ان نصيص تماما وستبقى هنا بعد
5000 عام من الان الان
على الاقل ما جاء في كلام ضيفه من الرجيم
قبل قليل كيتكلم بنبره فيها كثير من الغضب
رايتك تبتسم عندما تكلم واثار قضيه سنودن
وايضا التسمم عندما قال بان الصين قد
تتجاوزه الولايات المتحده اقتصاديه بعد
عشر سنوات
كابور
في تراجع بسبب سياسات الرئيس
والسياسه الكارثيه التي لها علاقه بكرونا
والقول الناقصين سوف تحرر اقتصادها ولكن
هذا لا يعني انها سوف تتخطى الولايات
المتحده هذا اولا ثانيا قال انه من غير
المنصف بالنسبه
قرار وانه يجب ان نتابع موضوع التجاره
الحره هذا فعلا يثير السخريه بالنظر الى
انه ياتي من الصين لان الصين سرقت همم
براءه الاختراع على ماريخا 25 عاما
ليست سوقا مفتوحه للتجاره هي تسرق الفكريه
الفكريه عفوا وهي تدعم شركاتها وهذا
المزيد من الممارسات غير المنتفه وغير
العاديه
وبالتالي هذا بمك ردا على ممارسات الصين
غير منصفه نعم صحيحا الولايات المتحده
تعملوا في مجال جمع المعلومات الاستخباريه
ولكن الصين ايضا تفعل ذلك هناك ادله
تستخدمها او ادله عن استخدام الصين لهذا
المعادات لكي تتجسسها على دول افريقيا ليس
هذا مخطئا ان تفعل الصين ذلك ولكن سيكونوا
فعلا خطا بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده ان
تترك لها المرجع لكي تفعل ذلك بحقها
الاخير بين الرئيسين الصيني الامريكي وكان
هناك مصطلح يعني طبعا ربما كان الاهم في
ما صدر من هذا اللقاء وهو الاتفاق على
اداره النقاط الاختلاف هذه الخطوه
الامريكيه هل ما زالنا في اداره نقاط
الاختلاف ام انها نقطه خطيره وخطيره جدا
بالنسبه لي
يوتيوب
انا اتمنى ان تتخذ الحكومه الامريكيه
خطوات في المسار الصحيح بدلا من اتخاذ
خطوات تردوا العلاقات
الصين تريد ان تفعل بكل حال الرئيس
الامريكي يفقد مصداقته ليس فقط
الغربيه لان هؤلاء الغربي
والتفاعل معها بطريقه ايجابيه بدلا من
استعدادها او من اعتبارها كانها صباح لا
اهميه له وبالتالي ادعوا الحكومه
الامريكيه ان تعود الى صوابها والى ان
تسترجع عقلها بدلا من ان تشارك في نظريات
المؤامره همم وتظهر للعالم هكذا
اذا لم تعد الحكومه الامريكيه الى صوابها
كما طلبت ما هي الخيارات المطروحه امام
بيجين للرد على هذه الخطوات قامت بها
واشنطن والتي ربما قد تمتد الى دول اخرى
عايشه
لا تريد
العقوبات والردود لا تفيد الاهداف بيننا
لكن كما تعرفون الكثير في واشنط يتحدث عن
حظر ممكن
[موسيقى]
لصادرات الصينيه الى الولايات المتحده
وبالتحديد حضر الصين بالاحرى عدد من
الصادرات المهمه في انصاف المواصلات
وغيرها من الصناعات الاساسيه
تفكر فيه بالنسبه
الموقف الذي تفضل به ضيفكم الامريكي قبل
2030 اؤكد لكم ان اقتصاد الصين سيكون اكبر
الاقتصاد الامريكي هو اصلا
135% اكثر من الاقتصاد الامريكي حدثنا عن
القوه الشرائيه وكذلك
قطاع التصنيع والانتاج اكبر من المانيا
واليابان والولايات المتحده
لننظر الى المصارات والتوجهات ثانيه
توجهات الكبرى حان الوقت لكي تتعامل
الولايات المتحده
كما قال الرئيس الامريكي في قمه عاليه
في واشنطن الدكتور ما في عندما قررت
واشنطن اتخاذ هذه الخطوه هل وضعت في
حسبانيا ما يمكن ان تفعله الصين
يسوى
استراتيجتها العامه
القوميه التي نشرت منذ اسابيع وبالتاليا
استراتيجيه متوازنه تسع الولايات المتحده
الى التنافس مع الصين ومواجهتها
بما انها تنتهك والمعايير الدوليه
اصلا تغش في مشاكل التكنولوجيا العالميه
تحضرون الشركه الغربيه التي تريد دخول
السوق سينيه وهي تدعم طريقه غير شرعيه
شركات التكنولوجيا وبالتالي الخطوات التي
يمكنها ان تتخذها مثل حاضر التكنولوجيا
وشركات التكنولوجيا الامريكيه في الصين هي
اصلا تقوم بها وبالتالي مره اخرى لا تلعب
بطريقه
الدكتور
الامريكيه الكبرى لديها مصانع في الصين
والعلم الجرف الايام الماضي ما يتعلق
بمصنع ابل في الصين ربما مثال حي على ذلك
الامريكيه دخلت السوق الصينيه خلال
السنوات الخمسه وعشرين الاخيره بعد نهايه
الحرب البارده كانت تعمل وانه مع تنامي
ثروه الصينيه ستزداد ديمقراطيه وستصيل
بعد عدد السكان وحجم السوق الكبيره لكن
الكثير منهم قد خاب ظنهم كانوا يعملون
الحصول الكثير من نافع الاقتصاديه ولكن
هذا لم يحصل
اذا الصوت يتقطع من المصدر فقط انت مكاننا
من تجاوز هذا الخلل في الفني الدكتور ماتي
يؤثر لضيفي في بيجين السيد فيكتور اييي
جاو في اطار ما تعرف به السياسه
والدبلوماسيه الصينيه بكثير من
البراغماتيه
باعتقادك كيف سيرد الجارب الصيني على هذه
الخطوه من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عن شركه امريكيه
تنفيذيين لهذا الشركات
في الولايات المتحده
الى
بوينج
بين دولهتين
هي قوه وحجم تاثير السوق الصينيه املوا ان
تظهر بعض الاحترام
تجاه الثقه السوق الصينيا بدلا من ان تضر
بالمصالح مصالح الاعمال ومصالح التجاريه
المشروعه لشركات الامريكيه قوموا بالامر
الصحيح احترموا الصين بدل من ان تستعدوها
الصين وامكانياتها الاقتصاديه هل اجراءات
كهذه كثيره ان تحقق للجانب الامريكي اي
اهداف وما نوع هذه الاهداف
صب واي
الامريكيه من اجلي منعي هذه التقنيات
الصينيه الخطيره من دخول الولايات المتحده
ثاني يعني هي تدعم المصالح الاقتصاديه
الامريكيه والعالميه كما اسلفت فقد شاركت
الصين في عدد من الممارسات التجاريه غير
منطقه
الامريكيه لكن ما فاته وان الكثير من
الشركه الامريكيه والغرب
من كثره انخره وعملها في الصين وتبحث عن
اسواق اخرى من اجلي ان تطمئنا بعض
المصنعين لانها لا تريد ان تعتمد اعتمادا
كلنا على ديكتاتوريه كذلك راينا ما يحصل
حين تفرط دول وتبالغ في اعتمادها على
النفط والغاز
مثل ما حصل حين اشرحت روسيا اوكرانيا
وبالتالي اذا قرارات اصيل ان تشطح تايوان
قد يتكرر الامر نفسه وبالتالي لنتحدث عن
مصالح من قومي ومصالح اقتصاديه امريكيه
دفعت الولايات المتحده اتخاذ هذا قرار
عيال هذه الخطوات الامريكيه نتكلم عن
شركات كبرى في الصين كهواوي وغيرها من
المؤسسه بالتالي
هل نتكلم عن خطوات مؤثره من قبل الجانب
الامريكي
عايزين او هندي
اكثر فلسفه من صانع القرار الامريكي الصين
دائما تريد التعامل مع الولايات المتحده
كما هي تريد ان تتفق معها ولا تريد الصين
ان تصل الى وضعه
تكون فيه
بمواجهه المتحده
سوف يكون نهايه العالم
[موسيقى]
ضيف من واشنطن الدكتور مافيو كرونيك
مستشار السابق بوزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]